we'll see how this goes this is a a new
experience you're now the third or
fourth person i've
brought in michael knowles into the
clubhouse folds
to hopefully not get too folded up but
to
participate in a type of live dialogue
that may be limited to
the next you know very short period of
time before it gets canceled or we get
canceled
i know i'm cancellation adjacent when i
have you on uh but it's
none of that then michael knowles who is
joining us
live your image is frozen but i i think
i can hear you still are you still there
i'm frozen how do i fix that i lost my
producer he went home
oh no let me see it's only it's only uh
three or four o'clock where you are
right
i know it's outrage we don't work around
here at the daily wire ever since we got
gina carano on or we just watch movies
all day
just it's just popcorn and mandalorian
repeats
wow that is that is the life uh
so folks on clubhouse are piling in we
got a good crowd already
but yeah i cannot see michael that is
weird that is weird
i'll text my producer all right let's
see if that would work
uh let's see i'm gonna go home here
and i'll see about going live we are on
youtube as well
and we are joined by some friends
on youtube and clubhouse so this is
great
hopefully michael will get his technical
difficulties settled down
he of course is the green at the wall
that's my that's usually how i i just
hit the tv when i was a kid you know
just pour your coffee all over the
keyboard that that'll clean it up
uh so we're talking with the expert
scientists as as
folks may know from our conversation on
prager university's book club
uh the word scientist or science
in latin means knowledge and it doesn't
mean wisdom right michael so
we had a nice conversation about that on
the prageru
uh book club episode about uh came out
about a month or two ago
and i figured i'd have you back i'd have
you on my show
uh because you know you have to rebut
all those things that ben shapiro said
about you when he was on the into the
impossible podcast
he didn't do clubhouse he refuses to do
clubhouse for some reason i'm not sure
exactly what
i know i've been trying to get some of
my friends to join clubhouse but then
you know i never really do anything with
it i i'm not an
early adopter which is why i have to
tell you i was very
hesitant to do galileo on the book show
i wanted to have you on
because that seemed very exciting but i
still haven't quite come around to
galileo
i'm a little bit more in the pope's camp
obviously but you did a good job
yes and we you know if i can't get on
with galileo clearly you know new
technology is going to take a little
while to get accustomed to
that's right although we both believe
that the universe is centered on
on us so uh we you know one of us is
probably right but
uh i won't say who so you're still
frozen but we can still be heard
on the uh on in the clubhouse and on
youtube
so you will be forever frozen and
unfortunately you were like picking
something out of your nose i think when
the
image froze yeah that's that's a perfect
uh
image to have here hold on i'm gonna
text more people and then start
screaming because
you know i think there's this
misconception on my show you know i
seem sort of nice but i'm not i'm a
vicious man
and i i physically abuse my staff so let
me
get them on the line oh my that was uh
just
following in the footsteps of your hero
and mine galileo galilei
so those of you in clubhouse we're going
to hopefully uh
have a conversation that you will not
lack for on clubhouse because it's audio
only on clubhouse
until they figure out a way to add video
to clubhouse but we're talking with
michael knowles of the daily wire of the
verdict
of uh reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
which i am holding up a signed copy
thereof and i've read this book cover to
cover now about six or seven times
michael
it is such a breeze it is so beautifully
argued and written
uh i just commend you on that and we are
all very much looking forward to your
next book
speechless which will hopefully uh
contain some words
and i am i cannot wait for those words
to come
together because uh we are waiting to
hear from that and
speech is what we are known for and i
think clubhouse is a great medium for
you as it
would be even for uh your colleague and
friend ben shapiro
and uh hopefully you know i pointed out
to some people i'm friends as you are
with eric weinstein you hosted him on
the verdict
uh he called it something like a
progressive uh you know speaks or
something like that it's
it was good because eric's very shy and
he doesn't like to speak very much but
um
but in that conversation or in a recent
conversation with eric who got me onto
clubhouse
i pointed out to him that he has
something like 2.5
uh you're there again all right let's
see if you can join again let's see here
now i see you all right all right let me
join let me add you to the right
how about this can you move can you
blink
oh you're blinking i see proof of life
all right but you can't can you not hear
me
oh you can i now i don't hear you but i
see you
so now i i i see you but i don't hear
you
say something again michael no
i don't hear you
i don't hear you i see you you're moving
now but i don't i know
no can hear you let me see
let me see here see
you can you say something but don't
hear you uh so that is strange
let's see here i don't think it's on
mayan the cent can you count give me a
count
a one two three i so you hear me yes
but you don't you don't i can't hear you
that is weird
that is weird stuff maybe a third time
would be the charm
uh maybe we should eject michael
uh from here and the mute's not on you
don't have mute on or anything michael
i show you at maximum volume i do not
hear anything
sorry for the technical difficulties out
there on clubhouse
and on we i'm sure we're going to get
this figured out
in no time at all this is high
technology michael is
in a studio slash man cave somewhere in
tennessee
somewhere where tennessean is ten i
believe in
but uh now he's frozen and i don't hear
him
wow this is getting much more soon i
won't be able to hear myself and that
would be quite a disaster we're gonna
talk with michael knowles about
science about politics about what it
means
when folks say to listen to scientists
what that actually implies and whether
or not
uh one can have sort of
almost religious faith in science here
we go let's see if he's there
okay michael let me add you
can you hear me i can hear you i can
hear you
and i can see you all right that's all
the time we have everybody that's all
the time we have
thank you for having me it's good to be
here i i want this to be the case in
point by the way thank you to my
producer who just yeah
uh i i want this to be the case in point
this is why i'm so
so skeptical of basically anything that
was said or
done after about 1352.
that to me that was that was peak
technology
it was that was peak technology we it
was peak
arts and culture and as as our society
decays so
too we like the wonders of these new
apps did you
look how they worked did you move to
mennonite country i thought you moved to
memphis not mennonite country
tomato tomato well it's great to see you
it's great to be back with you
we were together back in september i
guess it was
and uh and we did a wonderful episode of
the prager university book club
which you are the the host and the uh
and the really the proprietor of that
fine book club
which features all sorts of things but i
was the first one to ever give
a science overview and so i take great
pride in that
because you know normally what you hear
michael is that people like you
and i'm told you're more right-leaning
then left-leaning
i'm told that the democratic party of
which your book was written
reasons to vote democrat a comprehensive
guide um
i'm told they're the party of science is
there such a thing as the party of
science or does science belong to all
people in all parties
well you you would hope that science
belongs to all people who
want to pursue truth it's sort of ironic
that now a party
uh which at various times denies
objective truth uh would would call
themselves the party of science but of
course
they take on this label and i i think
there's a reason for it which is that
they they have embraced secular
liberalism or scientism
or any of these other isms as a sort of
replacement
faith and this is a faith that they want
to
have serve as the fundament of our new
modern society and the idea here is that
people in the old bad timey days were
were not only bigoted and racist and
sexist and
all sorts of evil but they were also
extremely stupid
and so there's no reason to take
seriously any of the things that they
believe
or to respect any of the institutions
and cultures that they developed
you know who needs st thomas aquinas
that big dum-dum when you've got
some random blue-haired atheist liberal
walking the street today you know they
have all of the answers and
they have an iphone if they don't happen
to know something off the top of their
head
they can always look it up yay science
and
as you and i know very well humility is
the beginning of wisdom
and i think that it's no surprise today
that
uh this kind of uh popular liturgy of
secular liberalism
embraces as its highest virtue pride not
even the pride of the pride parades of
the 1970s you know
very narrowly limited to sexual
questions but pride as
as the tantamount virtue which is you
know once considered the
queen of all vices now would seem to be
would seem to be the virtue that we all
exult and it's made us all very dumb as
we all
fashion ourselves scientists when i
think about you know science lately i've
been thinking about two different things
one that we're told to listen to
scientists and
i want to get your take on this because
i think a lot of times the word listen
is really implying obey it's not
necessary
only to listen to scientists as you and
i talked about in the prageru book club
event that we did together
was um you know aristotle was a
scientist you know he was the first
person as you know michael
to discover that whales were not fish
and i know you use that quite frequently
there in tennessee
i know it's a big deal for you uh but uh
but he also came with the laws of logic
and he also felt felt there were four
elements and that heavier things fell
faster than lighter ones etc
and so do you obey him uh do you not
obey him do you listen to him
uh you look at um otto uh
or or shall we say um uh let's see what
was uh what was the other example i've
come up with recently oh yeah
heber fritz haber was a scientist and he
was an expert
he came up with the process that made
fertilizer that allowed you to eat
breakfast this morning and
and half the world's food production is
based on the haber process that produces
nitrogen-based fertilizers
he was a great scientist and then uh in
1915 he was conscripted by the kaiser's
army
uh to uh to to create a shock chemical
weapons group
an actual troop within the uh german
army and he not only participated in
making the first
effective chemical warfare based on
chlorine gas but he also
volunteered and got three other nobel
prize winners along with him
so he had four nobel prize winners
volunteering to go into the trenches
literally and
spray chemical weapons on people and
never regretted it
he never expressed any remorse for it
even after his wife committed suicide
one of his children committed suicide
over their guilt he never expressed
guilt and later by the way tragically
in some sense his own relatives he was
of course a german jew
his own relatives were put to death by a
chemical by the name of zyklon b
which was produced by haber's factory so
should we listen to him
i mean so where do we go where do we
listen to scientists
what does it mean in your opinion what
are scientists good for
keeping in mind you are an expert
scientist well i am an expert scientist
because i try to know things and so i
therefore
satisfy the conditions of expertise and
of science i think your example shows
the point
very very well we're often told that
we need to follow the scientists because
science
works and the chemical warfare that
you've described
which was developed through scientific
processes it did work
the question is what did it work to do
when we hear that we need to follow
these technocrats in lab coats who who
want to govern our
our country for us even though none of
us seem to have ever elected these
people
uh we're told well they just know what
works dr fauci
probably he's he's honestly ignorant i
don't i don't think he's necessarily
being
deceptive here he says that i've never
publicly stated a political position in
my life but
you you'd have to have a very paltry
understanding of politics
to make such a statement dr fauci is a
professional politician
his job is public health so
half of that is a scientific field the
health side
and half of that is a political field
the public side public and politics
mean the same thing so dr fauci's
recommendations
certainly do work i know it's a little
confusing because he seems to change
those recommendations every single day
but his recommendations work to achieve
certain ends if we lock ourselves up in
our homes
for eternity and never leave and
telecommute and
don't see any of our friends and family
i strongly suspect that that would work
to reduce the transmission of say the
common cold or the flu or the sniffles
or something like that
but it would not work to give us a
flourishing society it would actually
cut against having a flourishing society
because there are prior priorities what
works
you have you have to know what you want
to do and unfortunately
the the left in this country and a huge
portion of the right are not willing to
acknowledge
that uh secular liberalism is not a
valueless
default position it is a value-laden
uh political position that has certain
premises and is ordered towards certain
things
but they're not willing to admit that so
you know to give the devils their due at
least on the woke left
you've got these new radicals saying
this is our vision of society this is
what we want this is what we don't want
this is what we think is good that's
what we think is bad
and we're going to use any means
necessary to affect that
whereas on the right all too often what
people say is
you do you you do whatever you want i'm
not willing to
offer a substantive moral vision or a
political vision and
of course what that has uh led to is
this kind of
technocratic uh liberal society
that that pretends that it doesn't have
any values when it's probably
the most radical values of of any regime
we've seen in
modern history when i think about you
know how a scientist can
be perceived by different segments of
the population on one hand
it's sort of appreciated almost as a
god-like status that as
arthur c clarke who is the namesake of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination which i co-direct here at uc
san diego
uh he said any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and then
as michael schermer has said you know
any sufficiently advanced you know tech
uh
magic is indistinguishable from god
something to that effect
uh and it is really true that science
has almost these god-like
powers we can extend life we can take
life we can modify life we can
understand the depths of the atom and
and unleash unrivaled energy storage
mechanisms
we can uh explore other worlds and and
and really it does come with this power
that you know i'm kind of curious
to get your take on it because we and i
haven't talked about this what is the
role is there a tension between the you
know
bipartite goals of of an all-powerful
all-knowing god
um who has benevolence is is this sort
of a
a gift to mankind that can be rescinded
like i do
with my children and and you will soon
do with your young
young man that you welcomed into the
world uh so
so uh lovingly a few months ago um are
these just gifts are they temporarily on
loan are they permanent and once you
give it
unlike you know toothpaste when i order
it from amazon you you can you can never
return it
how does it work in your mind does god
give us this gift with the expectation
that we'll do the right thing with it or
uh or what when you say gift are you are
you referring to
free will are you referring to higher
faculties of reason
about the faculties of reason that
enable mankind to
take on god-like powers in a certain
sense of modifying life not necessarily
abenicio and
x-nilio but but yes these these
reasoning powers that lead to
science and as many of my colleagues and
i seem to
uh believe is this most powerful force
that that must be wielded with great
with great uh
you know almost temerity and and great
fear in a sense so yes
yeah it's it's it is certainly a gift
and it's a gift that god will not
rescind
god is not going to take away your
reason but you can squander your reason
you can do that very well
we do have free will to to squander the
gifts we're given and so
you have to cultivate them first of all
in the right way
and it's a great responsibility because
it seems to me that the greatest saints
of history could have been the the worst
sinners of history
and vice versa their their powers are so
great
and this is the purpose of liberal
education that we seem to have forgotten
it
which is that you are you are educated
from a very young age when your mind is
much more
malleable to tame your base passions
and to develop your higher faculties and
your higher virtues
and because vice and virtue are habits
the more you do them the more you're
going to do them
it's it's why i think there's a heavy
debate right now
especially on the right over what the
nature of liberty
is you have some sort of left-wing
libertarians and even some right-wing
libertarians
who believe that liberty is just the
ability to do whatever you want to do if
you want to eat all the cookies in the
cookie jar if you want to
pursue your appetites to no end uh
you can do that whereas the classical
view of liberty certainly the christian
view of liberty
the but the but the even pre-christian
understanding of liberty and the
end crucially the understanding of
liberty that our founding fathers had
is quite different that liberty was
summed up by lord acton
who is a well-venerated figure by many
libertarians though perhaps
they haven't read this portion which is
that liberty is not the
ability to do whatever you want but the
right to do what you ought
to do you can use a simple example
consider a heroin addict
by the kind of modern shallow definition
of liberty
a heroin addict is the freest guy in the
whole world he can just pursue his
appetites
as long as he's got a couple bucks in
his pocket you know and
what freedom is that but we all know the
heroin addict isn't free he's the
greatest slave
around he cannot tame his appetites
why'd you have to bring up heroin
michael why i know starting to get the
itch are you
that's right this sort of thing uh you
know means that you don't have any
control over you
your will and you haven't you haven't
cultivated
those faculties of reason so this is
what really really worries me
when the left the radical left goes in
not just to high schools or colleges but
all the way into elementary schools
and uh and radically and farms education
away from that which would be edifying
toward that which is shallow and
ideological and ultimately destructive
is the problem is
that's going to have a lifelong effect
and if you do that to enough people
there goes your society
yeah uh just remind people we are
talking with michael
knowles the proprietor of the michael
knowles podcast michael knowles show
which you can get
as i do on any podcatcher michael your
video's frozen again
i wonder if you can i'm going to go
scream at my producer again yeah well
yeah
hit him with the book i haven't
developed my higher faculties of virtue
here
hit him with the heroin spoon that i
left over at your place last time uh so
michael has uh
several uh book projects well he's got
one major book in the works and one that
was a bestseller with
over 5000 reviews on amazon five star
and above i don't know how he did that
and that's called reasons to vote for
democrats a comprehensive guide my copy
is signed now you may not have it
and i don't want to give it away i hate
when you know podcast hosts have
have have me on as a guest and say tell
me your entire book and its thesis
and uh so that my listeners don't have
to uh don't have to buy it
no i will not do that but i will put in
a a
encomium uh for this book and also for
his upcoming book
speechless which could not be more
timely and i'm only worried
you know michael uh are you still there
in audio form or are you gone i am like
i can hear you okay which is good you
know that now i can really relax
that's right do whatever i want that
pipe that uh that cigar is
now you know that i am at the university
of california san diego what you may not
know
is that our library is the geisel
library
it is the library named after uh
theodore
seuss geisel and donated by him and his
family many decades ago and it contains
within it many books
and uh and and some of those books are
even his books and recently of course
you are undoubtedly aware
that there was a move to to cancel uh
just six of his books
only six uh and i'm wondering what uh
what is your take on that what's the big
deal there's still
34 other ones and we're not taking his
name off the library or off the
chancellor's house where
he lives uh so i'm wondering yeah what
what is uh you know
what what are the prospects for this is
this you know kind of being overblown or
are we living through a digital
fahrenheit 451
you're not taking the name off that
library yet
i think that's how you have to qualify
for you're not taking it off
yet but it does seem to me that in the
long run
uh all of these names are going to go if
this ideology is permitted
to uh to go along people have made this
observation that you you can't buy
dr seuss on amazon now you can't even
buy dr seuss on
on ebay now for those specific books
that are those books
but but you can buy mineconf by hitler
and that that seems a little bit strange
isn't it that uh
maybe there's some drawing that some
random person objects to in dr seuss
i think there's a lot that you can
object to in mind conf and yet that
one's allowed
this is not an accident it's not a
mistake the reason that the
liberal establishment or the regime or
the blob or you just call it whatever
you want to call it
the reason that they are going after dr
seuss is because dr seuss is actually a
greater threat to them
than having mein kampf be for sale
nobody but a handful of lunatics is
reading mein kampf
for lessons in how to go about politics
michael has disappeared just as he was
talking about
digital censorship so over mine folks we
are talking with michael knowles he is
experiencing some technical difficulties
if he only had
a cheap macintosh laptop like me
instead of a huge studio with cameras
and
and camera technicians and sound
engineers
presumably everything would be well with
michael but this is kind of an ad hoc
thing for him
he's sort of an amateur you know he
hasn't been doing this very long
so we will give him the benefit of our
forbearance
and i'll ask people you know to start
thinking about uh
potential questions you might want to
ask on either youtube
or on the um on the clubhouse chat room
we'll have hand raising for folks that i
know uh i don't wanna
open it up to everybody at least not yet
um so if you do have questions or
comments you'd like to make for michael
hopefully we will get him back
on the line and until then i will just
ask you to
check out some of the other videos that
i've done in this past week on dr brian
keating on youtube
and on clubhouse there's the tinkling
sound let's see
let's see here michael you were just
talking about digital censorship and
somehow
it went all all went dark are you there
right
i am here can you hear me i can hear you
now yes and i can see you i
i just gave you a about a three
minute brilliant answer yes i
soliloquized
can never be repeated and then i
realized that you could not hear me at
all
it can it can never be repeated again
i'm not sure i'm i'm not sure exactly
where i lost you
but this i was i was that you had me at
mineconf
you were you were which is the original
title of my
losing the nobel prize was minecon
you know the the issue with with mind
conf and dr seuss people point out that
it's
kind of ironic that uh you can buy the
mineconf but you can't buy dr seuss
but not really it's it's not it serves
the the interests of the liberal
establishment because
they need mein kampf in order to
call us all nazis and call donald trump
literally hitler
uh nobody but a few kooks on the fringes
or reading mind confidence
lesson but but dr seuss and more to the
point
of for instance abigail schreier's book
about transgenderism or ryan
t anderson's hilariously titled book
when harry became sally
those books that are really challenging
the the ideology of of the dominant
regime those books
do threaten them and so they need to
kick them off of amazon
and sadly all the right has been able to
muster are these sort of
limp abstract defenses of free speech
without willing to being willing to make
an substantive argument
it actually seems to me i in the spirit
of bipartisanship perhaps i'll
i can say this i think the left
understands free speech and censorship
a lot better than the right does and by
that i mean
that the left like uh herbert marcuza
for instance father of the new left
he wrote this infamous essay called
repressive tolerance
in which he says that uh you can't
tolerate intolerance and so we've got to
shut up the conservatives and we've got
to
promote left-wing voices people said
this is outrageous it's an inversion of
free speech
not necessarily if you go back and read
john locke in the letter concerning
toleration
he says we need to tolerate everybody
except for atheists we can't tolerate
atheists
john milton writing areopagitica most
famous defense of free speech in the
english language
he says we need free speech for
everybody except for catholics
and you know in a way i say this as a
papist
mackerel snapper myself i understand why
he said that because at the time those
religious wars were so threatening the
english regime
you would have lost free speech and
everything that went along with it all
speech regimes have some
limitations on them the american regime
has always
censored a broad swath of speech fraud
fighting
words obscenity until very recently at
least
threats sedition all these sorts of
things were censored now we have a
wonderfully broad
free speech tradition in the united
states but there are limitations to it
and i think what the left saw is okay
there's limitations
and we don't we don't like stations are
so we're just going to shift them in our
favor and i think
if we really want to fight against that
it would behoove us not merely to defend
these things in the abstract
but to go in and say this is true this
is false this is right
this is wrong this is good this is bad
but that requires uh courage and
unfortunately
our conservative leaders have uh
generally speaking have had the spines
of jellyfish
so those invertebrates uh i think you
know i often find it as i've had
conversations with friends that are on
the progressive side
and i always say you know this this my
my show is not politically
it doesn't take political science we
achieve neutrality by wild oscillations
uh politically speaking which means that
i'll have you on
and i'll have uh noam chomsky on or i'll
have lawrence tribe on and i'll have ben
shapiro on
and that reason is because i don't
really care to talk so much about
politics because i do believe and you
might
condemn me for this i believe we need a
safe space
but a safe space in which you can have
other ideas flourish that's safe
from political overtones even though i
recognize most things have political
overtones but you know my example is
nobody ever wakes up and says i hate
that republican constellation over there
that
that stupid comment you know that
democratic comment's going to ruin my
all day you know
no we don't do that and and that's good
and that's why it does trouble me when
when scientists when scientists allow
our work to become politicized and when
we
step into the political arena you know
in my book losing the nobel prize i joke
you know every four years
we get letters from you know 70 nobel
prize winners on which of the democrats
should be
the next president and and the fact that
they've never endorsed any you know and
and in retrospect yeah i had some
colleagues defriend me
you know when uh when bush was in office
or unfriend me or whatever because i
won this presidential early career award
for scientist engineers
and um and they said how could you
accept it from that war criminal and
manga
and then uh and then just you know eight
short years later or six short years
later when
when trump was in office uh it was oh
you know
why couldn't we just have that nice
george bush back back in town but but
my point was you know who cares as long
as they are
supportive of the scientific endeavor
which can be
jeopardized if we become too political
so my admonitions are as much for my
fellow scientists
as they are for for their own
self-interest in other words for the
benefit of science
as they are for you know me to want to
maintain science as a politically
neutral endeavor which i don't think it
is so much anymore
right well part of that is it gets back
to this radical subjectivism
that is a political problem that really
overtook our politics you probably saw
the smithsonian sent out a handout the
other
maybe a few months ago which said that
we need to stop using terms
like objectivity and hard work because
those are terms that promote white
supremacy
you say well that seems a little
offensive to me i don't know i talk
about the soft bigotry of low
expectations
but it's it's a real uh problem because
if i it actually gets to this issue of
kind of politically correct
language and free speech the only way
that we can speak to one another
is if there is an objective reality to
which our words refer
so if if words have meaning
and we can generally speaking understand
what the words mean then we can
communicate even if we have different
ideas about things
but if there is no objective reality to
which the words refer
if it's just to quote hamlet when he's
feigning madness
words words words or if uh to quote dary
dah
there is no outside of the text you know
there's no it's just
all so subjective then
uh then it's really our our political
discourse and
certainly our scientific discourse uh
ceases to be about the disinterested
pursuit of truth
as we can see it and as we try to find
it and it becomes rather a battle of
interests uh we we cease to be able to
speak to one another communication is
not possible at that point
we just become sort of grunting animals
beating one another over the head
with a club and it's why politics gets
so ugly and that's why
the scientific endeavor becomes
impossible at that point
right and i also think you know when we
when we do kind of dip our toes into
that
into that regime of let's see michael
you still there
all right we have lost michael yet again
that's okay he is tinkling back in there
he is
michael are you there again did you just
accuse me of tinkling
you're tinkling in i love it
by the way how's the experience uh now
you are an experimental cosmologist
because presumably
you are dealing with an awful lot of
dark matter produced by your young son
how is it going this is
very true uh thankfully my wife has been
taking the brunt
of it uh but it's really uh really
pretty
shocking how how all of that works the
the other
thing that i did not expect about having
a kid you talk about
science i expected intellectually to
like having a kid
but i don't know i'm not the most touchy
feely guy in the world
no i don't know you'd be shocked to hear
i don't exactly know how to talk to kids
or babies i figured
i'd hand them a cigar and a scotch or
something and say all right buddy you
know
what do you think of the yankees but uh
but i i knew i'd like it intellectually
and then and then that kid comes out
and you look and the emotional rush is
so intense i had been i'm such a
terrible husband
i had been furiously trying to finish my
book that was due on the same day as my
baby
and my son unfortunately chose to come
right on time he didn't even give me a
day window
so i'm in the delivery room furiously
typing and then my son comes out
and i look at him and i realize oh my
book doesn't matter at all
it's so minor compared to what
it is now in the world and speaking of
books you know when i
had our first child you know i was in a
state of excited delirium
and as i'm you know in the middle of the
night you know getting awoken
awoken for you know the third or fourth
time that night i just said get me the
instruction manual
you know but but there is no instruction
manual and i
i don't think that it can really there's
no experience that can prepare you for
right everyone's saying
yeah you can get work done before the
baby comes but they say oh catch up on
your sleep like
i can store up food pretty well i can
store up food with the best you know
as you know as an expert scientist you
know experts say
have six months of food on hand in case
of emergency so i keep it on my body at
all times
that's very wise it's very prudent of
you but it does that babies do come with
a bounty of cigars but yes
see kids are really you know i say like
you you could marry as i did perhaps i
don't know i've never seen your wife or
met your wife
but i you know might have married my
wife for less than pure motives she's so
beautiful
but there's no such and so selfish right
intrinsically there could be a selfish
component even though
you won't remain married very long if
you have a selfish reason for marrying
your wife
or your husband or your partner or
whatever but there's nothing selfish
about having a kid there's no
there's nothing like oh this kid is
giving me so much great you know
especially for the first you know my
father used to say i love kids
after they learn algebra and uh you know
they really don't do much
so as aristotle said we love our
children because we sacrifice for them
and
you love that which you sacrifice for
and it's made me you know much more
you know kind of uh attuned to things
that i never was as a sing as not only
as a single man but even as a married
man with no children
it really has an irreversible effect for
the good
of course because as you uh i think
rightly infer and as you say from your
own experience
sometimes when you see a lovely little
lass at a bar
and you decide to settle on up to her
and buy a drink
you maybe you have pure motives of love
and
but maybe you have your own interest in
mine too
but true love is is willing the good
of another and with your kid you know
the kid is
most of the things that my son is giving
me right now
are um bodily fluids you know most of
the things
are not really what we want to see at
two in the morning that's right um
but you the minute you see the kid you
just think oh i would
jump in front of a bus if i had to
uh to stop this kid from crying one
because it would be for his good and two
because i can't take the crying anymore
so maybe i'll jump in front of the bus
anyway
but you know that that really does put
priorities in order
and the other thing that it does is it
it made me
realize that uh women having children
is like the center of the universe and
we all get sort of wrapped up in our
careers and everything and that
that's great but uh it it doesn't even
come close
there's there's nothing even that can
approximate it yeah there really isn't
and you know there's a flip side of that
too
is that you know kids always love their
mothers more than their fathers you know
no matter what we do
and that's natural and i even feel like
they love their maternal
grandmother more than their paternal
grandmother but that's because they were
actually
inside of their maternal grandmother by
virtue of the egg that the
daughter had when she was born so it
kind of all makes sense to me
um i want to turn to human life and the
value of human life
uh as being debated there was an article
i sent it to our mutual friend ben
shapiro and he just kind of
rolled his eyes uh over the over the uh
internet lines that connected us
and it was uh this article by a
professor i won't give his name or his
institution because i
really feel like he's be clowned himself
the article was
uh humans are basically squirrels get
over it
and the whole argument actually started
with with uh aristotle and aristotle's
statement of
you know that mankind is is animus
politicus or something like that that
we're just
political animals that can socialize but
other than that we have no
uh superiority over the squirrels and
actually that same day on sunday this
couple weeks ago on the sunday time
yes i get this i get the new york times
and i get the daily wire i
i don't know too many people have had on
you know michael knowles and noam
chomsky on the same show and i don't
know too many people who subscribe
to both the daily wire and the new york
times but as
i'd be that doesn't make that same day i
was walking on the beach with my with my
brother and
one of my kids and i saw a hawk swoop
down
and and just eviscerate a squirrel and i
said
i'm not quite a squirrel you know and
and it just made me think
when when people really promote or
demote the human being or promote the
animals
to this level and they use science as a
justification for that
um you know i think it's i think we're
living in scarier times than we realize
and
and that was just as i was becoming kind
of in you know rekindling an interest in
philosophy you know i'd
you know physicists are notorious for
kind of looking down on philosophers
and i had kind of gotten over that as i
got more interested in
in and discussing uh things like the
nature of free will and artificial
intelligence which i'll turn to next but
what do you make of this resurgence of
you know humans are animals
you know mother nature is is god and and
we are just playing in this
sandbox of of uh you know determined
particles uh
that have no free will well it's it's
very shallow obviously i
i always loved the analytic philosopher
alvin planting his observation when he
said
of daniel dennett and richard dawkins
and those guys he said
you know the new atheists are far
inferior
to the old atheists the old atheists
made slightly better arguments
this this fellow who wrote about the
squirrels in the new york times he
he quotes aristotle correctly but uh
you know i don't think he really gives
him a fair shake the
the power of speech which makes us a
political animal
is a pretty important one noam chomsky
would have quite a lot to say about that
actually
that's right the fact that human beings
our conscience uh conscious rather and
that we have
will and intellect is quite a
distinction between
us and the squirrels and what's
incoherent also about the kind of
fattish new
materialism that we're getting from from
the left
is that the economic themselves
immediately so on one hand
we're really just meat puppets you know
free will
is an illusion and we live in a fatalist
deterministic
society and all of our hopes and dreams
and loves and desires are just
illusions because of random chemicals
going off in the brain
and better to just follow your own
appetites until you glut yourself and
die that's one
one thing that we're told and then on
the other hand
we're told that our physical selves
actually have nothing to do
with our actual identities right we're
told that you know i look like a man i
hope
but actually if i feel on some
metaphysical level
that i am a woman then actually it's not
even that my
identity is complicated i actually just
am a woman
and my organs and my dna and my physique
have absolutely nothing to do with that
so on the one hand
they fall into this materialist heresy
but then on the other hand they fall
into this what you might call
uh gnostic dualism this this heresy that
says that we're not
uh physical at all we're just souls
and really i think these people should
go back and read their aristotle a
little more closely
because the the reality that we all know
intuitively
about the human condition is that we are
bodies and souls we're hylomorphic
beings
and you you can't really separate one
from the other one and
this is why it's often said that science
is the handmaiden of philosophy
and you might say philosophy is the
handmaiden of theology and it's just
the thing that's sad to me is uh it's
not the ignorance
as ronald reagan famously said the
problem with our opponents is
is not that they're ignorant it's not uh
not that they don't know things it's
that they know so many things that
aren't so
they if they just went back and read
like even one
philosophical text from the middle ages
they would uh
they would unlearn all all of their very
foolish ideas
that they they think that they're
inventing the wheel all over again you
know
but they really don't need to do that
and their science would make a whole lot
more sense if they would take their
philosophy seriously as
as you have done and it's why you speak
of it so well
yeah and and to me i see a resurgence of
this in many
forms and now michael has departed but
hopefully only temporarily so we'll get
him
back on the line when the tinkling
resumes or on clubhouse with michael
knowles michael is tinkling in there he
is let's add him to the right there you
go
hello blink two time there you go
totally tinkled so i've been pointing
out kind of as a
as a tweak as a provocation to my fellow
scientists that
there are none so religious as
scientists in many ways in fact
we even have a religion that i call
nobleism
which actually has a founding father
alfred nobel it has
its uh holidays the the ceremony of
annunciation and the coronation
of laureates that takes place not on
alfred novell's birthday
but on his death day macabre lisa
and uh and it not only has its its
patron saints the
the laureates who win nobel prizes uh no
no fault of their own you actually can't
nominate yourself for a nobel prize
trust me i tried
uh but you also have the apostates they
the the
decriers of it the uh that rail against
the priesthood which is the swedish
academy of sciences
and and we actually have our share of
golden graven
uh medallions that feature a picture of
alfred nobel that you must bow down to
to receive and i think it's so funny
that scientist even today i just saw one
from
a scientist by the name of michio kaku
have you ever heard of him
i can't say that i have i don't follow
him on twitter yeah okay well yeah
maybe you should he's he's he's he's
does quite prolific tweets
therein but he and he might not be on
clubhouse maybe i'll get one clubhouse
but anyway
the uh the tweet was something like if
you want to understand if you want to
win a nobel prize
and do something einstein i.e another
patron saint
was unable to do just come up with the
god equation
the equation that explains all of all of
matter and the theory of everything
and and here it is this appeal to
authority by someone who's presumably
secular
i've heard him talk about it before but
certainly there are other people
very secular lawrence krauss is a very
prominent new militant
self-declared militant atheist and yet
they'll invoke these things
to the same effect that i hope for our
next book uh in all seriousness we'll
talk about
stephen hawking's a brief history of
time which is perhaps the most
famous of all popular science books
which was written from a deeply
atheistic perspective
wanting to prove the invalid in validity
and
un uh on in necessity or not lack of
necessity
uh of god and in fact the whole book is
about
the invalidation of hawking's uh belief
that the only role of god at the time
was to start the universe off to create
time in other words
and in his book he comes up with a new
theory of time which he assumes is true
and no physicist ever really took it
seriously and nor do they now
and he says that the only role of a god
would be to instantiate time
and we don't need that because here's my
theory uh the hawking heart
theory that time comes out of naturally
emerging
and so we don't need god and in fact the
end of his book ends with if we can
you know get even more evidence that i'm
right uh then we will truly know
the mind of god what is it about these
scientists who are admittedly
atheists not only secular but atheists
and and their need to appeal to god so
often
well of course they need to do that
because man is fundamentally a religious
being
and no amount of uh c.s lewis said
you can scribble darkness on the walls
of your padded cell but it's not going
to block out the sun
and so they have this natural longing
but it's really sad when you see people
who are so intelligent
like many of these scientists who just
don't know a damn thing
about philosophy or theology and
uh i i i i've tried reading some of
their books on the topic
i haven't tried reading many of their
books on their actual areas of expertise
but i have tried reading some of their
books on on
pop religion and it's it's embarrassing
i mean it's the sort of thing that
if they were a freshman in college you
know would not be accepted yeah i was
going to say sophomoric but yeah i'll
take
what it is it is it's not even
sophomoric you know
and uh and if you actually study this
question
you can find at least a dozen good
arguments for the existence of god
uh the existence of god which can be
known through human reason from the
natural world
and knowledge of whom is is obviously
expanded greatly by revelation
but whose existence can be known from
the natural world i can't think of a
single good argument against the
existence of god
and uh you know you can hear these sort
of
various uh i don't know materialist
feelings or or impulses but you know
we've discussed some of them earlier
they're just they're just very silly
and the one argument against god i guess
that really does convince people
because it's so visceral is the problem
of pain the problem of suffering
the odyssey yeah the odyssey is what
it's called and
uh but really i think if you think about
it a little more closely the odyssey
becomes
actually an argument for god uh so even
that that doesn't really work
but i would just encourage them to open
up their thomas aquinas you know
if for no other reason than to not
embarrass themselves when they
venture into waters that they just
really have not exploited what's
yeah what's so funny to me is that you
know lawrence krauss and i consider him
an influence i personally like him
and you know he came up with this book a
universe from nothing which
which richard dawkins called tantamount
to charles darwin's origin of species
and
no no physicist takes that that
particular claim seriously but
just the just the level of comparison
because i do think that humans have
a need not only to be political but to
be religious
and when you think about you know a
religion that's kosher so to speak uh
i look at it again in and thinking about
um this week so and as you know from
your
connections to certain jewish
individuals the jews read the
old testament once per year which means
it's divided into 52 portions and we
read
one uh one per week and then this
particular one has to do with the golden
calf this this this shabbos is this you
know tomorrow's porsche
portion read in synagogues around the
world has to do with the worship of the
golden calf
and i always point out you know one of
the objections famously kind of
pithily summarized by woody allen he
said i really want to have belief in god
but there's no proof there's no evidence
so i would settle even for a divine
sneeze
a divine sneeze and and i always point
out like no you wouldn't
like like first of all i think you know
jews are rumored to be somewhat smart i
mean maybe my
my company excluded but uh we make up
something like 20 or 30
of the nobel prize winners and i'm only
saying that because other people use
that as
as attribution to our to our
intelligence i think i don't know of a
single physicist nobel prize winner
who's been
religiously practicing and that that
that's my counter example to folks who
do bring that statistic up but anyway um
when i think about someone like lawrence
krauss who was jewish
born jewish and they graduate from
judaism at age 13 in other words they
have their bar mitzvah and that's it
that's the end of their judaism if they
even have it
now i actually was an altar boy in the
catholic church when i should have been
having my bar mitzvah but that's another
story oh that's right that's right
yeah but but from the perspective of
like we need something to worship and
here are these jews
back in they just witnessed 10
miraculous undertakings by the divine
creator they heard
god you know according to the story
right and then uh and then just for
40 days later you know when moses
carries for a little bit you know he's
late to a meeting and who hasn't been
there michael
i mean he had his he had a skype thing
crashing back then
but he was late by like a few hours and
all of a sudden they start making a
golden calf
right and and how much has has human
nature really changed in 3 000 years i
would say not much so
would it be a proof i mean people that
say give me show me proof and then i'll
believe and and there are people even
from
you know ellie wiesel and and others
that i have a great deal of respect for
that basically have the most simplistic
the my favorite one is this
professor avi loeb who is israeli but
secular
he wrote a book called extraterrestrial
about this uh this object that he claims
came from an
extraterrestrial intelligence and he's
quite secular
and uh and he says no you know if god
really wanted to
uh have abraham not kill isaac or
attempt to sacrifice
he should have just like had a voice
recorder invented back
you know 3000 years and i'm just like
you're a brilliant guy like you know and
you know the torah the old testament
better than i do probably by virtue of
where you grew up
and yet you're saying something so
simplistic it's just against human
nature
we have a desire i think more to than to
believe
to reject belief and i wonder why is
that why why are so many people that are
intelligent
why do they want to reject you know
something even just religious practice
even just being what i call
myself sometimes a devout agnostic in
other words
practice some form of religion because
you're going to do it in one way or
another
and do it do the good deeds that
religion impels us to do why is there so
much hostility towards that among my
fellow and our fellow scientists
well you'll be shocked to find out that
the cause of this is the fall of man
which is talked about in that simplistic
little book
that so many scientists might take issue
with pride is the is the cause of the
fall
and whitaker chambers actually in the
political realm writes about this
in his excellent book witness whitaker
chambers very famous
ex-communist and he uh he converted and
became a christian
and he described communism not as the
absence of faith
he says that communism and i think we
may say more broadly kind of
secular leftism the kind of dominant
ideas that we have in our country now
he says it's the second oldest faith it
is the great
alternative faith for mankind and it
began not
when marx wrote in the 19th century but
it began in the garden of eden
when the serpent said to eve ye shall be
his gods
and so pride causes the fall and
people who are very intelligent often
come to look like fools that this is
also something that's observed in that
little book that
probably some of the scientists haven't
read which is that
the wise are made to look as fools
because they are so intelligent
and they are so uh hot on their own
supply
that they that they can't recognize
their own
finitude their own mortality their own
uh their own limits of their intellect
you know
this is a distinction that i loved so
much i think it's the most important
uh speech given in the 21st century it
was given by pope
emeritus benedict xvi it's called the
regensburg
lecture he gave at the university of
regensburg i think in 2006 i want to say
and in it he he got in trouble he was
told this was politically incorrect they
thought he was being mean to muslims but
he actually wasn't
he was quoting a medieval muslim scholar
uh
and describing this the difference
between christianity and islam because
in christianity
god the second person of the blessed
trinity in jesus is identified with the
logos
the the divine logic of the universe so
god according to christianity is
logic uh according to islam
god is allah is utterly transcendent
so god is pure will
if allah according to this scholar who
he was quoting ibn hassan
if allah so willed it he could make his
people
worship idols and there would be no
problem with that whereas
the god of christianity would would not
do that sort of thing to invoke the
golden calf
this is where we get our civilization
from the idea
that reason and faith are not in
opposition to one another
but actually go together much like free
will
and grace go together dancing is as if
to be dancing a waltz together
you're not quite sure exactly how how it
works but but it really does go together
uh that is what is now being so
undermined
by people who are full of pride as we've
discussed
but who also for intelligent chaps just
don't know anything about about what
they're talking about and and
to watch these sort of intellectual
spiritual and cultural destruction all
around us you just want to
scream and say guys you're smart stop
doing this you're destroying the very
culture we all cherish
very good so i know we only have a
couple minutes left so uh those of you
on clubhouse who are
known to be known by michael or myself
if you have a question or comment
please raise your hand and i will take
those otherwise i can open it up
uh brought more broadly to everybody if
you do have a
quick question from michael or for
myself
the last thing i want to ask you about
is a familiarity perhaps with this
with this notion that artificial
intelligence is going to be
increasing at an exponential rate
continuing to increase and an
exponential rate we've all seen
images videos of dogs robotic dogs
dancing
you know the macarena and all sorts of
other fun things which which i
um you know terrify me but also uh
titillate me
and there's a notion that we know we're
gonna have this this augmented
you know capacity thanks to computing
power and technology
first of all i don't believe that we
need more intelligence i don't believe
we need artificial intelligence
i'm more interested in artificial wisdom
but that's a subject for another day
um but i wonder you know do you what do
you subscribe this the so-called
simulation hypothesis
that eventually will get to be so
powerful that computers could get to be
so powerful just according to moore's
law
that will have enough computing power to
simulate any event in the past history
of the universe that's coarse-grained
enough for human beings to interact with
in a classical schedule
uh classical level so what do you make
of that simulation hypothesis that's
something that you've thought about
well brian my multi-million dollar
production studio that i'm sitting in
right now
cannot get a simple skype call to work
so i'm i'm not so worried about
terminator at the very moment um
but there's no question of course
technology is going to progress
i think though a lot of these
technofuturist types
fall into the same foolish error that
we've been discussing among scientists
which is they don't recognize that man
has fallen
and these things tend not to work out as
the
great prophets of them or as the sort of
dim shallow prophets of them think that
they will
i guess my my friend father george
rutler has this line he says that the
difference between a scottish optimist
and a scottish pessimist
is a scottish pessimist says things
can't get any worse
and a scottish optimist says oh yes they
can
and i suppose this is a little bit of my
take here
is i i the reason i don't uh fear
so much the kind of simulation
this perfection of a.i where we don't
know what reality is
is i think it's just going to get a lot
worse and i think the fallenness of man
is going to corrupt that progress right
and uh as technology does get more
powerful
is going to create probably uh just just
lots of problems along the way for us
okay we got time for one question uh
maybe two from
norman and from gideon so you are on
with michael knows michael on your phone
unmute yourself and you can talk on
clubhouse and i will try to make this
work out all right let's see
my understanding of it is that typically
uh
the people who believe this sort of
thing think we're already
in the simulation and so they kind of
start
having this weird quasi-almost god-like
belief that like coincidences
are evidence of the simulation
acting again i was wondering wanting to
get michael's take on
what is behind that particular heresy
that
the joe rogan and the sam adam not
saying that
sam harris probably okay
uh sure gladly i my thought on that is
that all all nature is but art
unknown to thee and all chance direction
which thou canst not see
as as alexander pope once said and
actually coincidentally uh because i was
just quoting my friend father george
rutler
on a book where he used that quote he
had a line that he wrote himself and he
said
an evil generation looks for signs and
wonders but a stupid generation
ignores signs and wonders and what i
think these people who pretend that
we're living in a simulation
uh believe is that they want to avoid
the the reality of providence you know
that
there are these coincidences actually do
often tell us certain things
the traditional uh certainly the
catholic view of the world but i think
more broadly a religious view of the
world
is very semiotic it's rich in symbols
because we know
that the physical things have
metaphysical meaning they
they refer to things that are that are
formal and are outside of this
finite creation and so i what i strongly
suspect is
people have the the eerie uncanny maybe
numinous feeling
that there is some meaning in the world
we're not just a bunch of meat puppets
but they don't want to face the reality
of what that means for their behavior
and ultimately what it means for
the reality of judgment what comes next
very good so we had one more question
michael you got another minute
i do have another minute okay good
norman you are up to bat i will
ask you to unmute yourself and you're
talking with uh michael j knowles
oh that was mike that was norman okay
sorry gideon i screwed up
and put you back in the audience you get
time out
you get scottish punishment um let's see
uh gideon you still have your hand up so
let's get you back up there sorry
gideon is now up gideon please ask your
question michael
great man you have excellent taste
gideon i can already
though he was an tell democrat support
the internment of japanese americans
and all these things and suddenly he's
racist now even though they don't even
realize
that and then sorry then they say that
fdr is like
the best president ever or whatever so
i don't know what's going on with that
yeah can you repeat the question michael
just for those that didn't hear
oh yes gladly am i still muted or can
you i don't know i just i i
i'm getting feedback on my side but you
couldn't just write a question about fda
yes so the question was why are they
going after dr seuss dr seuss was a
liberal democrat i frankly don't even
really like dr seuss oh michael sorry
unmute your your clubhouse microphone oh
i've got to unmute my clubhouse yeah
so this is why the machines are not
going to take over
this is why i'm because i'm not too
worried yeah they're going to hear me
yep okay excellent so uh the question
was
why uh why is the left canceling dr
seuss dr seuss was a liberal democrat
ann coulter actually tweeted out today
she said don't cancel him over his books
about mulberry street
cancel him over his books that were
making light of the soviet union
in the in the 1980s you know that's the
real problem
um uh so the reason they're doing it i
think
is uh not to not to refer to a cliche
here or
invoke a cliche but it we can learn
something from 1984
and i know that conservatives are never
supposed to invoke george orwell because
he was a democratic socialist and
conservatives don't understand his book
well first of all the socialism of
george orwell was quite complicated and
i write about it in my upcoming book
speechless
uh but more than that uh the the i think
the
comparison is apt because orwell says in
1984
that the regime the big brother regime
relies
primarily on newspeak changing the
language and on all these memory holding
different historical
figures like for instance dr seuss but
also on
doublethink doublethink i think is the
key here which is
if the regime can force you to hold
contradictory ideas
at the same time they will have
succeeded in cracking your humanity
because they've cracked your power of
higher reason
and you will be unwilling and unable to
articulate the truth
so they'll say fdr is the greatest
president ever fdr who interned
japanese americans but dr seuss
who i don't know he like drew a
caricature that frankly is not offensive
i don't know
most of these characters he drew are not
not particularly offensive i guess some
of them are
uh he has to be castigated and cast into
outer darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth
the reason that they do this is because
of the contradiction
the fact that we are now told that we
have to be feminists and believe all
women
but also we have to recognize that women
don't exist and men can be women and
women can be men
the idea that we need to i mean this is
actually this particular gender example
is clearer
when you consider the arguments for uh
greater acceptance of homosexuals they
will say
well it's because you're born this way
and if a man is born this way
then he's attracted to men and therefore
it would be wrong to tell him to
not pursue those desires and so
love wins right but then the argument
for transgenderism is that
men and women are not really fixed
categories and you can just if you have
some surgeries or if you actually just
change your mind you can you can become
a member of the opposite sex
those are contradictory ideas andrew
sullivan gay conservative wrote an
excellent essay on this a few years ago
but the contradiction is not going to
undo the the
regime the regime is aiming at
uh undoing our
recognition of the faculties of higher
reason
and and so uh i i think they're going to
keep it up and they're going to tear
down certain statues that don't make any
sense and they're going to put up other
statues but
ultimately they're tearing the whole
edifice down because we were discussing
this a little bit earlier if we can't
have any reasonable conversation then
which i think is the end of this whole
project then ultimately we're just going
to be
grunting warlords you know beating one
another over the head
and pursuing our interests and our our
baser appetites and
uh i hate to leave us on a low note
there but uh
you know when when we invoke things like
the science of history you know you
always hear this from the left side
well the arc of history is long but it
bends toward justice or
you're on the wrong side of history or
something like that they're going back
to a
long-standing concept on the left which
is that the leftist political scientists
have discovered the science of history
they know how it's going to go and it's
kind of a deterministic thing
well christians certainly have a sense
of that too
i think jews do as well sort of
eschatology the idea that the world is
going to end
it's going to follow a course we think
it's going to follow a different course
i think than our
radical friends think it will but
surely that that that is a disagreement
and we all know things are going to get
worse but
in in the meantime if we can try to
preserve
something of our of our culture and
preserve something of a reasonable
society and be able to communicate with
one another
we might have some some ages of darkness
but uh
but uh perhaps there will be light that
will uh will come up again
very good well michael knowles author of
the uh
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
and the forthcoming speechless of which
he is not
usually found in that such a quantum
mechanical state
like i want to thank you for your
courage and maybe you'll come back again
because there's a whole list of
questions that i demand answers to of
all my guests
including uh including what's your
prediction on bitcoin
including some topics about the the
pressure of fame and
and sort of the achievements that you
really unlocked at such a young age and
i think i think of you as a very
courageous person you know
uh obviously you know we don't always
agree on stuff and and
and that's okay then that's the purpose
of intellectuals
that we can debate and we can have
committee with some comedy
and i just love uh i i love what you do
i'm a huge fan
i'm so delighted that we got a chance to
work together uh the prageru book club
episode it's called the dialogue with
michael knowles you can find that
uh on prageru or on youtube and you can
find us
riffing off of one another and i hope to
have you back again michael thank you so
much have a great weekend and
kiss that cute little baby for me
thank you for having me i look forward
to having you on my show and then uh
chatting again soon by the way in answer
to your bitcoin question
going to the moon and coincidentally i
have a little piece of the moon also
thanks to you that is right
that's right you give me a book and i
give you a piece of the moon
all right my brother have a great
weekend we'll talk again soon bye
everybody